breaking news germany's largest bank
that's right the largest savings bank in
the country of germany is now going to
allow their customers of which they have
over 50 million customers to buy sell or
hold bitcoin this is massive news
anytime we can get a legacy organization
like a bank or a financial institution
who has tens of millions of customers to
go ahead and onboard them into this new
digital financial system it's a big deal
now ultimately what we have to look at
is a couple of things one allowing
people to buy and sell this asset makes
a lot of sense the bank probably thinks
they can make money there but they're
also going to allow them to hold it and
anytime a bank is going to underwrite an
asset and they're going to be able to
say that their regulators their
insurance companies and their custodians
are comfortable with that asset that's a
big deal it means that there's a
maturing aspect of the bitcoin market
now here in the united states it's a
little bit different banks today are not
allowed to have their customers buying
and selling or holding bitcoin the occ
and a number of other organizations are
working to see can they come up with a
framework can they underwrite it can
they get comfortable can they get
educated enough to allow banks to
actually have their customers buy sell
and hold bitcoin within their regulatory
framework i personally am bullish on and
i do think that we will see banks allow
folks to do this and so the second that
we have united states-based banks
allowing tens of millions if not
hundreds of millions of customers be
able to buy sell and hold bitcoin the
adoption will start small there will be
very small kind of one percent of
customers doing it but it'll grow over
time and ultimately what i believe will
happen is in your bank account or your
digital wallet you will hold all sorts
of different currencies you'll hold them
for different purposes you may hold
bitcoin as a store of value and then use
us dollars as the medium of exchange on
top of that you may hold other types of
assets right there alongside it
ultimately in the age of information
everything is information the same way
you send a text message you can now send
currency the same way that you send
currency the same way that you can
actually buy and hold a store of value
ultimately it is simply digital assets
and that to me is the true beauty just
as the internet brought the friction and
cost of sending information around the
world down significantly we are watching
bitcoin do the exact same thing for
money for a store of value and so it
makes complete sense why the largest
bank in germany and other banks around
the world are all trying to get in the
game they are watching a monetary and
technical revolution underway they're
watching people flock to this new
digital store of value and they don't
want to be left behind ultimately there
are banks that have been super
successful navigating tons and tons of
different technology evolutions they've
been able to be around for the advent of
the telegraph and then the telephone and
the internet the pager and the fax
machine and many many other technologies
they've navigated all of them
successfully and they're still here
today those banks have been around for
100 plus years but there's other banks
that were in existence but got disrupted
and so my ultimate belief is that if you
are a financial institution a financial
organization and you've been able to
navigate other technology revolutions
you have it in your dna your innovators
you constantly are looking for the next
new thing you're probably gonna be okay
you're probably gonna be one of the
first adopters of bitcoin or other
digital technologies but if you don't
have that in your dna as a legacy
organization you're likely to be
disrupted because the innovator's
dilemma doesn't hold anyone immune to
those classic forces and so ultimately i
personally believe that over the next
decade or two we will see every single
bank that survives go ahead and
incorporate bitcoin and other
technologies into their organizations
though like the lower cost the faster
speeds they like the automation and
overall they will give their clients
what they want and with over 150 million
people around the world already adopting
holding buying and selling bitcoin the
people have spoken they want bitcoin and
the banks will have to get on board